final day of P dat and we'll start right
away with our first Speaker Hadi Abdi
haste with his talk about knowledge
destillation in which a smaller network
is trained to mimic the output of a
larger teacher model um Hadi has been
working at the Delta tray group as a
research and development engineer and uh
he'll tell you more about the topic
itself Hadi thanks for introduction just
give a warm Applause for thanks
hello everyone and welcome to the
session uh as uh that was a warm
introduction my name is Hadi I'm working
at Delta trade group um been working in
a um industry around 10 years right now
from uh dedicated Hardware programming
to cloud-based uh Services which
actually serving millions of user
luckily they are still in production um
Delta tray is actually the we're leading
a sports entertainment technology
provider we're offering uh Ott live uh
graphics and broadcast Solutions uh I'm
part of Delta TR Innovation Lab at the
lab we are uh providing different
services to the units uh around the
group so we uh basically doing analytics
uh and U Know Technologies uh I'm uh ESP
specifically working and uh analyzing
the videos from our own uh cameras in a
sport venues uh through the streaming
analytics and like understanding uh the
Dynamics of the fields making statistics
and so
on
um today um we're
actually uh about to delve into the word
of knowledge distillation as you might
know and uh we will start by providing a
brief introduction to the nor networks
and transfer learning uh we will will
explore various variants of uh knowledge
dis solation and finally we wrap up with
a straightforward example so hopefully
during this talk you can uh have a bit
of idea how it works and how you can
apply it and maybe after that you can
just go and read if you're interested
more so to kick things off uh let's
begin uh with the basics uh we all know
uh the building blocks of nor networks
so as uh you can see at the left bton we
have the input which is indicated by X
we will wait at them and uh as an output
function uh we will soften them or
filter them uh uh based on a summation
of a weighted uh
X so stacking these NES together uh
creates layers and when we are stacking
layers together we will come up with the
network based on the architecture um it
can have like building blocks in between
memories and so
on uh but let's say uh you will get
something like this which you have an
input and you will get the outputs uh
based on this connections and weight uh
and you are training this model it means
you're changing the weights uh using
your label data so the
output is trying to be like the the same
as the um
labels so we are using a l function to
fine-tune the models and parameters
based on the like label that we have
here so now uh let's discuss about
transfer learning a
bit uh imagine you have a nor networks
uh like this it's like uh web of
interconnected neurons uh let's say uh
you can have any architecture here we
have for example CNN convolution nor
Network you have a matrix of colors
which is a image you will put it inside
a network and uh after your calculation
you will come up with the probability of
a classes so the network is actually
classifier uh you will put a image of uh
something let's say the network is uh
fine tune on a general task of image
classification it can understand any
objects uh you will put an image it will
tell you whether it's boat or car or
bike um and the probability on
them uh based on the literature that we
know
um the first layers like at the left
side um trying to understand the
lowlevel features like where the borders
are or uh where the edges in the
pictures are and once you are going to
the uh end of the networks it will train
meat uh and the high level features of
the image so uh the last neurons trying
to understand if it's boat or car and
the beginning they're just like doing
image processing let's
say so
um before going to transfer learning uh
imagine
um we have another task
like you are about to understand whether
there is a um bike in a picture or not
so you've got that Network that I just
uh mentioned it can understand any
objects but you are to just solve this
subtask small task of from that like big
task so what what we can do is actually
keeping all the first layers so still we
need to know the borders and edges but
maybe we don't need the last layers of
high uh level features and we can even
like discard the boat and car and just
keep the bike one right so we'll just
change the last neuron here and we'll
keep the rest of the networks maybe
we'll will train it in a a small various
unlabeled data as well and it might work
very well as people shown before all
right so uh what we should do is just
um um use uh the same network for a
specific task and making adjustments on
top of
it um let's say you need to change the
network uh somehow
um for a high Lev task so you might uh
want to recognize different various type
of bikes which you haven't seen in your
image data set it it had like General
bike and still this network can help you
uh in a sense that can do some mid-level
and low-level features but maybe you can
just add few layers at the end to
understand uh what is different between
bikes I actually even don't know it when
I'm seeing it in Amsterdam right now
it's like a 10 type of different bikes
right so we can still keep the part of
network but we can add more layers
instead of one neuron or one layer or
like few neurons at the
end if is that makes
sense so that's uh what I wanted
actually to tell you um if I can change
this slide okay um
so what what if uh we find ourselves in
a situation where like this example that
I told you is actually overkill for a
relatively a
straightforward uh task that I just told
you so you have a picture you're just
going to say if it's bike or not right
you don't really need a really big
capacity to understand all the word and
all the classes and then uh classifying
the bike
right so maybe we want to uh off for a
less uh resource uh intensitive approach
like a smaller Network which can feed uh
comfortably in memory or you want to
host it in your Edge
device so we we already know this task
is simpler so we don't need that uh big
Network to do
so so let's
say um this is where knowledge dis
solution come
from uh the concept is to use a bigger
Network so-called
teachers uh to train the smaller uh
so-called a student
Network so what the student networks
going to do is actually copy the
mechanism uh of teacher networks mimic
the teacher
network uh as as as as a source of
Truth so once you have have uh something
really huge like a teacher Network here
which can understand everything maybe as
an student you can go and just uh learn
a specific part of things that you want
for your soft task
right so let's visualize this
process so we have a student Network and
the teacher network uh let's say teacher
network is the is working on a bigger
task so we will feed the uh training
data to both
networks first we will uh train teacher
networks for the train data and then um
a student data a student network doesn't
learn uh from the ground truth labels so
it's actually
um uh rather than that uh it learns from
the soft labels or probabilities
predicted by the teacher
Network and then uh after
your training procedure hopefully if you
had enough capacity in a student Network
and I'm assuming you are also using the
full capacity of your teacher network uh
teacher does its best you can come up
with something maybe at the same quality
of a
teacher so uh this process uh allows the
student model to grasp not what or let's
say car labels are but also why the
confidence behind those labels are
right
great um but let's
say you are about to
um train
the B
Network or or let's say you have a
bigger task so you want um like okay you
don't like to have a bike uh or no like
classifier so this uh Network going to
distinguish various type of bike as I
said okay so you didn't have it in your
teacher or maybe your task is even uh
more sophisticated
than uh various type of
bikes so what we are uh going to do is
again using the same knowledge because
starting from sort of random Network
might not be the good option we already
know the lowlevel feature so what we can
do in this
case
right so building up in the previous
step
that I showed you uh consider this
scenario that I just said right so you
have larger
task so in such cases um you begin uh
with the better initial
point and you can do the same so again
you will put the training data in both
networks a student Network first will
train on the labels from the output of a
of a teacher
Network and then um you will use the
student Network for
your next task later on maybe you have
some
uh relatively a small sort of data
set so the network is already ready to
understand what is in the image so you
will just train it let's say fine tune
it on top of your small label
data
great but what if uh your task is not uh
only the subtask of like General task
it's the combination of different
tasks so you need you need to again uh
train a complex
Network so in uh this case imagine you
want to also segment where uh segment a
bike where the bike is uh what's the
type of the bike uh and maybe even
writing EXP explanation in text so you
have different tasks and you want to
somehow again use this uh Knowledge from
other teacher networks to somehow come
up with another Network which does
everything end to
end so let's explore multitask
distillation here imagine um you have
this General task and also maybe you
have
uh sort of
limited uh data to train it as well so
we've got uh for example this this
network which is segment the image we
have another Network which is classify
the
image uh we've got another Network which
is maybe uh localized uh objects so
we're going to use all of this this
network for your source of
truths we know the various aspect of
this task are available online so we
will just employ multiple
teachers
as source of truths so what we're
actually going to do is interesting
instead of uh combining the network data
and labels we will use again the um soft
and labels from output of these model so
we will aggregate all the input together
maybe it's only one image or maybe you
have text as well so it's just a general
uh Shema so maybe you will just put an
image but the output can be the various
predictions that you want and these
various
predictions uh are the ones that should
be uh train on top of the output of that
teacher
networks great so having understood the
concepts uh let's get hands on with a
state for example so I'm just going to
show you how it works in tens
oflow uh you can do it in any framework
uh and I'm just going to show you the
things I uh explained it's not that
difficult to implement in First
Step so our first step is to load the
tensor
flow uh and for this task I'm using a
toy uh data set mnist so let's load it
as well and then
um we will need to change that uh
representation so if you're not
unfamiliar with amness is the
handwritten uh numbers you've got 28 by
28 uh uh
pixel images and this image images are
showing the
handwritten numbers so for now we're
we're changing them from 2D to 1D array
and then we will
uh embed them like we will represent
them like in a one hot encoding because
there are the pixel colors of image we
will just uh also uh change the domain
of the numbers from the input so we will
we will show the nine if there is a nine
as an example in your data set so we
will show it by 0 to one like like that
Vector you'll see in the
image uh then we Define the teacher
Network so this is more complex Network
so let's say we have few layers like
five layers of norms stack to each other
so for that we we are using a Danse
networks we just stack them together we
will we should
also somehow uh Define the activation
and here we have the call we will just
St stack them
together um in contracts we need the
a student Network this is a compact one
so here you can see it's only has three
layers so it's uh more simpler than
previous one we'll do the same but for
uh with the same input but the uh less
layers and then we start by um loading
the tissue model uh and defining some
hyper parameters let's say uh we should
train it by a crossentropy
loss uh and optimize it by Adam if you
are using another version of tensor 4
maybe you you should use optimizers do
legacy.
Adams um but anyway if you will fit uh
compile and then fit the network you
will come up with some um accuracy like
97 82 and
tested um we suppose to have the same
quality in a student let's see if it's
worked right that so I already run this
code before as you might guess um and
then once the teacher model is trained
here and we will freeze the layer of it
it means that because we uh during a
training of an other network we're going
to get the prediction of this uh Network
as a label of the other network so we
need to just freeze so-called freeze
these layers keep the V and not changing
them during the training of other
networks so we will just freeze all the
layers to keep it as it
is and then um here is a critical part
so let's say the student uh loss
function is calculated based on the
teacher models output not the True
Values that you have so we should Define
our custom loss function here so we will
actually do the same so we'll get the
out get the output of a network and
we'll put it in the L function of the
other one so and we have like other high
parameters like the EPO numbers and the
bat size of the other network once you
will fit this one
uh as a result the validation accuracy
of u a student is um
9782 um nearly matching the uh teachers
performance but the tricky point is um
this is not the one that you should look
if you are working with tensor flow you
should uh go and see
the real numbers on the test set so it's
it's relatively the same so but this
network has less layers and less
Norms great
right and let's take a moment to recap
what we've covered so
far we delve into fundamentals and I
just show you quickly the various dis
solution learning
techniques uh mven uh simple practical
uh
implementation so before we conclude I
would like to also recommend some
resources what I showed you is a basic
so please uh take a note or I will just
share the slide later with you uh please
go and read this ones you will find out
more about the backbone of this uh
techniques it relays your setup what you
are actually going to do and the tasks
and uh basically if you have labeled
data or unlabeled data or so
on and as a
bonus uh for those who are seeking to
quickly start if you got the GPU you can
consider torch dis still it's a
framework which simplifies the stuff uh
it's like high level written so you can
see the example here I'm finding
transform model for glue task it's a
text classification task you will just
call it and you will put the input file
as a config it will Ro load the teacher
by itself and it would train the student
Network for you to see they got I guess
um around 20 new recent uh techniques
you can just run them and see the
differences if you
like
and I guess I should say thank you all
for today if you have any further
questions or uh wish to connect so I'm
available after talk and I'm also be
happy to answer any questions right
now